okay hello everyone we are doing a w
from language design review about leader
and organization data something that we
have long had versions of of malfa and
we are now trying to clean it up to the
point where we can expose it in W from
language
so where do we start we we've done one
review of this already right so this is
now yeah there's there's a handful of
things up front that are just kind of
small tweaks that we had made from last
time there's some other work that's been
happening in the background that we've
still got a bunch of uh can I make a
suggestion these these I mean I think
having a color difference between I like
this very much I'm kind of wondering if
we should gray down the
position we talked we we proposed that
last time too that that might make
sense okay I just think it be easier to
read and uh right I mean we could do
that you know we can do whatever we want
in the The Entity boxes with
formatting when you got the you know say
the name property or apply a common name
to that MH we're okay with it's just
going to be the string
Nevada Governor James W NY I guess so I
mean one thing that I guess can happen
is people's effective names can change
when they become you know king cougal
wole or whatever and before that they
were Bob Smith or
something true
right so is that happening and and what
do we you
know I mean
I well the
the this this
entity points to a specific person data
entity and so you know we I see there
there's an underlying question there
about should we have a should names be a
Time series we have that in some domains
we haven't really done that for people
yet where we indicate you know this
person was this name until this date and
then it changed I for the yeah I mean
for the most part for these kinds of
things these organization position
tenure
things I think it's it's just going to
be whatever the name they had while they
were in that office I guess still
somebody could change their name while
they're in office but sure yeah but I
mean but but the office itself could
Define a
name as you know King so and so would
often right
yeah
um and I think for this you
know yellow box exposure we are going to
want to say King so and so because
otherwise it's going to be very
confusing if the person was called Bob
Smith and then they became king so and
so you know you're kind of not okay
here's another example okay you know
William Thompson became Lord
Kelvin that's not so much now that
that's a name time series I me there
plenty of of um
uh there plenty of people who change
their names for all kinds of different
reasons whether it's a um then there's
the kind of people with overlay names
like you know entertainers who go by you
know you know Q or something yeah but
they real St stage name or pen name
pseudonym or whatever else right right I
mean generally the way that we handle
that in people data is just the the name
by which they most commonly go in
whatever their you know public facing
Persona is is what we use as the just
name property but then we have you know
full name or birth name for for other
things and there can be a lot of other
steps in between that that's something
else we've been trying to talk about how
we represent that we don't really
represent that in a clean way that
someone could have changed their names
many
times
right we just kind of have the the name
they given and the name that they
currently go by or last went by if
they're they're deceased and then maybe
some alternate names that they went by
but without an indication of what time
period those refer
to okay for these though I think I for
the most part I think these are going to
be pretty straightforward but I agree I
think that the the making a distinction
in these boxes between position and
person
right even in this case yeah yeah right
I mean it's a little weird it would be
Greek Prime Minister would be but but in
fact it's like Nevada Governor it's not
nadic Governor or something right
actually Le Leroy and I were talking
about that this morning that was that
was a thing that that he had brought up
where you know for for a given um like
president of the United States is a good
example like the the organization
position entity is president of the
United States but when you're when we're
making these boxes it would be much more
common for someone to say US President
Joe
Biden and so I think there's there's
also we want to think about how we how
we construct those and and your your
point about Greek versus Greece I think
is also Greek to me sounds more sensible
I wouldn't say I president would you say
France France president or would you say
French president I would say if we could
have separated punctuation or something
between France in other words if it was
if they were different colors if it said
France prime minister or president or
whatever uh you want to break break
break them down
into preserve the atomic parts of the
things instead of trying to trying to
make it a a title that we're showing in
right I mean you know by the time it's
dutch antillan whatever or something
something even more obscure than that
you know Fijian whatever it's not what
you want to see you want to see Fiji
president
blah because I mean again think about
the US states what are the adjectival
forms of the US states I don't even
know
illinoisan yeah that one is okay what is
it for Nevada nadan nadan yeah okay all
right okay really obscure
tonian okay it's
obscure I think we can all agree that's
not if you live in Nevada you just okay
fair enough the what what is it from
Massachusetts good question I've never
heard an adjectival
form
um so I think we should try and figure
out massachusett
or
massachuset great you know massachuset
Governor great the yeah yeah it's
obviously silly um okay so or there's
well never
mind there's a vul vulgar form that I
won't say um when I was there everyone
would say Bas stor right wow okay right
but we're not going to use that
obviously so so let's figure out how we
I mean yeah so you you're suggesting a
design that that preserves the
separation between yep organization or
we got jurisdiction Place yeah we got
the thing like Denny's for example down
here in the next piece here you know
president CEO director yeah Denny's is
one thing position is another thing the
person's name is another thing yeah
okay
I if we needed to we could have you know
visible a visible separator here now
what we do in terms of of the common
name is unclear to me I mean I have to
say I think a list would be much more
useful than a smooshed
string I mean just like we do for
possibly you know New York New York
United
States
well although I mean I think we the
common name of that is still it's just a
string that has commas in it you're
suggesting actually a a list of
strings what is the common name let's
see for New York New York is it is it
still just
um
okay oh well for New York that actually
that's that's one of those cases where
we've we've we're not
consistent oh or maybe we
are no I guess know for for the cities
we we do just use the the city
name Nam name yeah
but you know this this one here I mean
what does that do right now I know this
would was it would it would just be the
first part of it would just be Nevada
Governor James
W9 I
see
well could be worse I mean it's not it's
not terrible and there you know if you
if all you wanted was the person then
you know there's a there's a position
holder property to get it the just the
person if that's what you're looking
for an interesting question whether we
should do some kind of nesting of um if
you say entity person of this thing
whether it should be the equivalent of
position
holder
what I'm saying yeah I
mean as a convenience it doesn't seem
like it would be hard to support
that okay let's let's um okay keep going
here
okay right yeah the the position type
before we had only initially only had
this set up with a single position type
and then especially in the case of
corporate positions we realizing that
there
tons yeah sorry yeah there's tons people
often have you know right and you would
you would want you'd want to be able to
look up you know who's the who is the
president or the CEO or whatever and and
so having these things represented as a
list and So Below you know that's being
able to to construct an implicit entity
class on whatever kind of
granular position you want you're going
to still get the same person but then
there are also things like the you know
the lower case that's that's stray that
wouldn't that shouldn't be exposed in
the the language that's the sublabel
property that we use to format the to
inject the dates into the um entity
box sorry this this ambiguation not seen
that before it seems like a useful thing
for us to have in in um in the
properties of some entity and I've just
not seen us use that before um I mean I
I'm sure that I think that's just how
the we have a suel property that shows
up elsewhere we use that
in word senses I think in some of the
species stuff in Foods I I can't
remember if it's exposed as a property
or it's really just something that we
use as
a right I'm just suggesting nice
property to have it could be yeah I'm
not sure that I mean this ambiguation
2022 to present I'm not sure that's a a
useful
property for somebody and you've got the
date it's just formatting the date
information in a different way no I know
but I mean it could be differentation
though yes yeah okay um but then we have
also that has things like you know the
lowercase leader I that this one just
had redundant ones
well but we want to be able to support
lookups on things that are not
necessarily the in the list of specific
titles that a person
holds right like what are we going to
have what is that is that is that
another entity
type organization position type okay I
mean that's that's the question we could
talk about there being more of a
hierarchy of things but it could also
just
be we have a mix of sort of levels of
position types I mean this could be
things like leader it could be things
where there's more of a distinction
between
head of state and head of government um
you know there there are other kinds of
categories of positions or leadership
levels that would make sense to be able
to look
up I understand and you're saying we
have to expose those
somehow right
um and the question really
is uh you know I'm sure that there are
sort
of you know somebody could have a title
esteemed leader could be their official
title and I think we need to make more
of a distinction between you know the
actual
title right that that's CEO or director
or whatever else that would appear
officially an our descriptor like uh you
know chief executive or something which
is a different thing right okay
or we we touched on that briefly last
time and note further down the notebook
I think about what what we do in the
long term
about weird titles like that you know we
we would want to be able we definitely
would want to be able to display the
title that a person uses for a given
position but we would also want to kind
of normalize those things and have them
match up to to General categories as
much as we so my suggestion would be
that that we have things which are
official titles titled positions so to
speak and then we
have sort
of generic positions or something
descriptive position title positions and
descriptive positions a title position
is you know would be on a resume type
thing right descriptive position would
be uh you know like leader for example
which generally
wouldn't be a resume
position fair
enough now what do we do with positions
that are you
know vice president of rainy clouds or
something you know some these companies
that make up these kind of you know
cutesy
sounding uh titles where are we putting
those Like Chief imagination imagination
officer or something yes but I mean much
much even sillier than that in a sense
you know something like you know uh
chief of plant rights or something no
that that even sound plants as in Chief
of vegetable rights you know the
companies have it's gone a little bit
out of fashion you know 15 years ago or
something there was a big or maybe 20
years ago there was a
big push particularly in the tech
industry right for for giving people
really you know these cutesy tit
right um what do we do with those it's a
good question I mean that
there's there's an unspoken thing here
which is that the corporate data is the
really hard part of this just to get in
the first place um you know the
government stuff NGO data anything with
other kinds of public
organizations not so hard to get the
data for companies that would have a
cheap
plant welfare officer um that's hard to
come by are you suggesting that it's
it's just a goofy name for an otherwise
sensible title notar position maybe
incomprehensible what
yeah uh you know there'll be I'm sure
they're right now already like like
instead of HR you know there's you know
there's head of AI r or something right
you know um look it seems to me it's a
little bit like units where there are
canonical units and then we have this
idea of of sort of an independent unit
yeah um because clearly they are
canonicalized things like you know
companies have a president a secretary a
Treasurer right in the US at
least and that's canonicalized and you
know the notion of a director is
canonicalized
um uh you know one thing a corner case
we're not dealing with here but I don't
think we need to is co-presidents for
example uh we touched on that last time
I think and we
were there's no reason that we can't
have two separate entities
representing different people in the
same office covering the same time
period or even disjoint time periods
that
overlap yeah okay fine all right so
there's nothing here we can't there
there is actually there's there's one
there's one side note and Lisa reminded
me of this yesterday
um something like President
um you can you have the president of the
United States you could have the
president of
Denny's um if we did a lookup for
organization position 10 years you know
position type president where the you
know the position holder was born in
Illinois yep right now the way that's
structured we' get you know US
presidents and people who were
presidents of random organizations if we
happen to have
them a little deal yeah
right a little weird and so I mean you
can you can imagine having sort of you
know do we Clash on a a government
mental president
versus company president and and there
is I mean we'll we get a little further
down here one of one of the core things
that I think we keep running into as
we've talked more about this since last
time is there are some some fundamental
differences between corporate positions
and things like government positions or
positions that are in other kinds of
organizations um and just some we wanted
to do here but
well there's you can you can say things
about the presidency of the United
States you can say things about the
president of the United States that are
independent of the people who hold that
position that are you know you've got a
there's some legislation that determines
that set the thing up that determines
how it's appointed there's a salary
there's a seal there's all these other
things there's not
I mean University president they have a
house they live in they have a sure you
know they probably have a SE that may be
true but but but what about the you know
the the CEO of
Apple like the question well I mean
question is sort of fundamentally like
it makes sense to me it makes sense I
think to most people here that there's
an entity for us that represents the
president of the United States does it
make an equal amount of sense for there
to be an entity that
represents the POS whatever position of
Apple I think probably yes I mean I
think it I think it gets less and less
sensible as the organizations get
smaller and
smaller right well we talked last time
about you know followed to its
conclusion then we've got the the
chairman of the champagne unit for
school board or something and we've
got yeah
that's surviving position that position
even if the person who's in that
position right now disappears that
position will either and by the way then
we also have the situation of the
position exists but it is
vacant which is a useful thing for us to
know
true now you know the creation of a
position like clearly if company a is
bought by Company B the presidency of
company a might disappear
right and
the the role that's performed by the
person who's in position X at this
company that position may change into a
differently named position with a
different scope of Duties and all sorts
of other things but they're sort of
equivalent but there are lots of
differences right but that's okay I'm
not sure it just it just gets St I mean
part partly this is just kind of
wondering if there's it should we be
thinking about there
being should we bring sort of
hierarchical entity stuff in here and
maybe there maybe there is a sensible
split where there should be different
types of positions that President one is
one one that kind of highlighted that
because there are there would there
would be even if there could be
properties of the The Entity that
represents the CEO of Apple there would
be properties of
you know the president of the United
States that would never apply to the CEO
of Apple yeah but but I mean yes I
understand that but but okay the
question is the word president for
example is it simply that that has been
abused and
reused between the government and the
corporate sector and that really those
are two different concepts you know
corporate president and Country
president I mean I I don't I don't know
if they're really that fundamentally
different I think it's for me it's more
a matter
of letting users try to get at what they
I understand what they want let's say
that somebody says you know president of
[Music]
um
uh thinking of a of a company
uh I don't know British company X I
don't know I'm not for some reason I'm
lanking on British quintessentially
British companies but a company that is
you know a department store I don't know
if they still exist tesos in England
grocery store chain or something um I
mean you know in other words that that
entity will have a managing director it
will not have a quotes president even
though functionally those things are
fairly similar if not identical
right so what do we do with that in
other words do we trans
translate you know I I actually don't
know I mean many companies operate
primarily in you know even quite large
companies that operate primarily in one
country uh I don't even know whether
they would theme if somebody says you
know I need to talk to the president of
your company um you know do they have I
mean it's like like you know I'm sure if
they were traded on American Exchange
they would have to define a person in
you know with a map
of the name of you know the president is
blah I suspect that's a field when you
fill out you know the SEC filing or
something
right right so what do we do
with okay so there is a
title maybe we're getting ourselves hung
up because there's a
title and there is a position the
position has a functional role
mhm and it might have a
certain legal so I mean where does the
legal sort of relevance of that position
you know the uh
uh you know who's responsible when this
or that
happens
um
oh gosh well maybe we should keep going
here I mean I fine my tendency is to say
that
title is different from
role yeah I that possibly even there are
three things title role
position I don't quite know what
position means there I I I mean you know
leader
you know in in a sense there's you
know you know for a
company there sort of quotes ultimate
leader in some well depends what you
mean by that I mean depends how the
company is set up I it could be the case
that the the CEO is the ultimate leader
it could be the case the chairman of the
board is the ultimate leader depending
on how you look at
it
uh you know some companies
and I mean okay like outside the
US there
are what are they called management
boards and I mean like in Germany I
think there's a a
um like something like an oversight
board and a management board or
something and one of them is external
people the other is internal people
those kinds of things
right I mean there might be an executive
committee
within the
company of internal
managers yeah right so I I don't know
how I mean that's a question how does
this
work I mean if we look
at financial data filings for these
companies non- us
companies what have those Services
typically
done I
mean
okay if it's a
um oh my God what those was called U ADR
um you know company that is listed on US
exchange right right
um there is presumably paperwork
associated with that where even if the
person is called Grand puar in their
native country Bas have to fit into some
set of right canonical position roles
yeah right which are more like like what
we should be dealing with because then
we can
map
their
um
uh gosh I mean you know for us going
through the US
designated
names with Linguistics that allows us to
deal with you know the the Swiss name
for such and such a
thing seems like the right thing to do I
mean you know it could be the case that
they are fundamentally different and
that might be true for example when we
get on to militaries I have no idea
whether every you know whether every
military is organized into you know it's
a hierarchical organization of you know
platoon and divisions and this and that
and the other I have no idea whe I'm
sure they're called different things in
different countries but I have no idea
whether they're functionally the same
right
[Music]
um okay Le let's let's keep going what
what questions go ahead well I mean that
the the the big question for me was just
trying to think through the the
difference between governmental and
corporate and other kinds of
organizations these these may or may not
be helpful to you they were helpful to
me just in looking at um this is kind of
the wiky data hierarchy going from you
know CEO versus president of the US and
what things those Wiki data entities are
instances of subclasses of or parts of
which are kind of three of the the key
relations in Wiki data that that map out
that those kinds of relationships
between
things like the president of the US is a
it's a subclass of the the more generic
presidents which is a subass of you know
head of state States
person looking at things like this just
to try to think through what some of
those higher level um General position
types might be for different things um
just starting to seem more useful to me
understanding how this stuff fits
together
yes but then you know I mean it's Wiki
data so it's also yeah right that's
that's the thing
once you start going out in Wiki data
you get all kinds of weird little
nodules that people have have stuck in
there right this one looks not very
useful this one looks more useful but
that's probably because there really is
a pretty well- defined set of things
here right well and that's and again
that's the thing that's that's more true
of a lot of government positions because
these are things that are you know
they're they're really well codified in
some Constitution and they're they're
supposed to hold up over a long period
of time and generally they do and
there's a lot of things they have in
common that that's just the two of them
glom together they really they really
split off in very different ways yeah
crud here right the other thing we were
talking about before was
um what do we what do we call some of
these things like when we're talking
about a president versus a CEO and what
organizations they are tied to or in
charge of and what their jurisdiction or
you were suggesting something like
domain of responsibility there's a lot
of this stuff that the exact phrasing is
is kind of hard to pin down it's also
another thing where jurisdiction is
something that tends to be pretty easy
to understand when you're talking about
a governmental position it's harder to
to
say with some clarity when you're
talking about a corporate
one why I mean corporate organization
tends to be
hierarchical um yeah but what are what
are the the the what are the things that
are showing up in the values of
jurisdiction
companies but I agree that it gets more
complicated but it might be a division
of a company
right
uh and also and we've had some we fall
on different sides of the fence on this
one
but and again Wiki data is not the final
Arbiter of this we get to decide how
this works for us but when you're
talking about someone who is uh the
president of the US president of Italy
Secretary of
something is the if we're
thinking the organization that they are
in charge of you know if there's an
there's an Associated
organization is that organization the
country itself or the organization is
you know as kind of gets represented
here
it's it's the executive branch of the
federal government or it's it is the the
office of the presidency of something
the responsible for the US or is the is
the president of the US actually
responsible for the executive office of
the president or something right the the
organization that they are the the EXE
the chief executive of is not the
country the country is a different kind
of entity they are the chief executive
of of a specific chunk of the
government right I mean in particular
people will have a staff where they can
you know hire and fire people in their
staff but in the country at large it's a
quite separate thing
right and sometimes there's a whole
mechanism you know if there's an agency
somewhere of the government there's a
whole piece of machinery for you know
hiring people in those tentacles and so
on right and we have I mean we have
really Ro right we have entities that
represent the governments of different
countries and some departments when we
get down to that level we just we
haven't exposed those yet and we hadn't
really talked
about do we want to does that make sense
do we go down that road we have an
entity that represents the the
government or the executive branch
or this Council of whatever that
somebody is actually officially
the yeah leader of all
right I mean I'm thinking of really
weird cases
like always yeah some of the I mean
there are like some of the blockchain
organizations how so well because it's
like who's in
charge I mean I don't know is well
Bitcoin isn't an organization as
such something I mean I suppose there
are the
yeah they often have a foundation and a
company and this and that I guess those
are separate entities are you thinking
something like a DA the decentralized
org yeah yeah yeah yeah we can have we
can by the time we're representing a DA
here um I think we won't worry about
that case okay you know eventually it's
an AI is in charge more or less or it's
a uh or it's a pure da where nobody is
in charge
where it's just yeah let's let's not
deal with that heads spinning a
case
um I mean aren't there and here I'm
showing my lack of knowledge but I mean
aren't when people have you know
communes and things don't they have some
you
know I'm showing my lack of knowledge
and na here but but um you know is the
theory that somebody is in charge or is
the theory nobody is in
charge I think they tend to operate on
like a co-op principle right like
everyone is kind of in charge but it's
done by
committee social Collective yeah okay so
those are a hopeless case for us
here I mean but in those cases there is
no
leader that right I mean even though you
know obviously some countries have tried
to theme themselves as being in
principle that but they actually
perfectly well do have
leaders true although if I mean if
someone has a a an actual title or
formal role we're not we're not just
modeling people who are in charge of
things we're modeling people who just
have a defined TI role
yeah yeah general secretary or
something um whatever assistant to the
deputy secretary is something what
represent to yeah right fair enough okay
so let let's zoom out for a second right
so let's let's try to understand what
is
okay we have the entity that they are
associated with like United States
versus executive branch versus whatever
else one question
is yeah is it a different POS position
that they are US president versus that
they are commanderin-chief
or does one entrain the other so to
speak I mean clearly we need to be able
to make the query who's
commander-in-chief of the you know of
the Fijian military or something and if
that happens to be the president of
Fiji
then you know we should be able to right
determine
that I mean I'm sure that there
are you know I'm quite certain I I know
in England at least I'm sure it's true
in the US that there
are sort of pseudo honorary like like
I'm sure you know the chairman of the
Smithsonian or something is probably you
know the vice president or some such
other thing I have no idea I made that
up but but you know there are these kind
of in trained positions so to
speak I think we touched on that a
little bit last time like was it the the
vice president of the United States is
also the president of the US Senate yep
right but those are but those are dis
those for us would be distinct
separate
entities
okay so in other words Al although there
although we should have some some place
where we model the fact that one
is comes along for for the ride with the
other see I mean the problem is it comes
along for the ride until it
doesn't you know there are these things
which have been you know oh it came
along for the ride for 200 years but
then suddenly somebody decided to sort
of split them apart sure
yeah well I
mean I can I can off the top of my head
I think of kind of handwave ways of
indicating that where we you know have
some property relation that's
saying typically
Associated positions or just Associated
positions and you know if if the same
person holds it at the same time then it
was very strongly Associated then and if
there's a period when it wasn't then
there are just different people in that
position well they continue to have one
position and then secondary position
might change like they might be chairman
of the board of a company and it's CEO
for a while but then they stopped being
at CEO but they continue to be chairman
of the
board true I think then those would be
separate I mean either either we're
representing those as two separate
tenure entities from the beginning where
someone is chairman of the board blah
blah blah blah blah and a separate
entity CEO blah blah blah or we
have chairman and CEO blah blah blah and
then when they drop one of those
roles there's there's another there's
another entity that gets created but
it's sequential with the original one
yeah oh my gosh oh
yeah world's a complicated place as we
knew um it is yeah okay so all right how
do we what do we need to make forward
progress here I I mean I think there's
you're you're inclined to
to say
that uh CEO of Apple is a is a valid
entity unto itself the thing that I was
okay I think we could proceed a little
more with assuming that we're going to
set that up I think we've Leroy and I
were just talking about the
government uh governments and agencies
as organizations so we can expose those
and look at how that
gets uh exposed here with organizations
those kind of organizations versus
companies and
jurisdiction will we'll populate those
out more for corporate entities and see
if that makes sense when we look at some
of those
examples um
okay I think
no I think some of the other naming
ideas I think we can we can let's let's
make some changes and come back and look
at some more get some more specific
examples where we've got more data
exposed the design for these things too
for the see about the entity The Styling
of the entity blobs right I do think
that breaking apart title from
functional position or something is
worthwhile yeah are you are you thinking
just that those
are you talk about different fundamental
entity types or that they're all still
organization position types but we break
them into separate properties associated
with the people so they should different
types I think that the you know there's
a title thing that's pretty clean and
it's like what is the title for this
person and that you know that could be
replicated in the functional position
so to speak the title could be
CEO and the you know that could also be
a functional position but the title
could be I mean you know like for
example okay remember Yahoo They had did
not have a CEO they had a chief Yahoo
yeah so we is that kind of
imagining well president president of a
country versus president of the company
they're still they're still titles but
then we also have a president that's
a role or what are we calling it
position functional functional something
we need to name it but
yeah where somewh your example from
before where somebody is their title is
managing
director but in their list of things
that are functional position
whatever a generic president might be
there yes okay or chief executive is a
more likely thing
either but I don't know what the heck we
do with something like Chief
Yahoo I mean was he anything other than
effectively of a CEO no was just it was
just a cutesy name for
CEO
right so then I mean that's that's the
title I guess the question is do we what
what mean what's the formalize that yeah
Ian we have to have that somewhere right
if you were gonna if you're
gonna or do we not try to canonicalize
that and that's just a string that we
have somewhere as another property
that's well I mean maybe it's another
property yeah it's it's like
um and he has a there's there's a
there's a title and the entity in the
title property is CEO but there's
another property that's just strings
with whatever goofiness was associated
with that t yes
okay see I
mean you know I'm I'm just wondering
where do we put you know her Majestic
Excellence you know queen of of whatever
whatever whatever whatever whatever
separate separate separate properties
with forms of address associated with a
position for I'm not sure to address I
think the official position if you
looked it up okay on a resume would it's
then it's an official it's an official
name full full formal name or something
we find some more examples and see yeah
formal name might be I mean we could use
formal name for chief Yahoo as well
that's true no yeah you're
you're you're absolutely
right
um we don't need a separate category for
stupid
names the
um yeah because I do think okay yeah no
that that that's that's a useful
breakdown I think I mean it's a little
bit of re rejiggering of the the
entities but there aren't that that many
things that we need to shuffle around we
can we can deal with
that right because in particular for for
example for Kings on Queens don't they
have a lot of for example territories in
the full full format oh yeah yeah oh yes
they do right lord of the whatever and
yeah and yes supreme ruler of this
particular Rock in the middle of the you
know Southern Ocean or something
MH uh
so maybe we should have an alternative
titles or something like that
or yes but I'm I'm well I don't
think I'm just thinking I
mean what is the corporate analog of
that
it's you don't get that as much I mean
people tack on you
usually yeah you you don't see
that in the case of countries you know
somebody conquered the rock in the
Southern Ocean or something and then
they add that onto the
title whereas in the corporate case it's
more like it got absorbed into the brand
of the of the purchasing
company I mean that could be the case
you could
say uh you just don't see that in in the
corporate case that I know
of the these long trailing titles that
say
lots
uh interesting okay all right anything
else we should make sure to cover here
no no we'll we'll round out the notes
and and work on the stuff that is
practical to work on and come back and
continue okay okay all right thanks a
lot thanks to folks on the live stream
see you all
soon
bye